first thanks to Toyota for hosting and
allowing me to talk it's been really
great so far so I'm talking about this
package developed by Twitter there they
call it breakout detection they
developed it maybe 2014 by a group of
people there and it's a package that
detects level shifts and time series
data or in general univariate data so
this is this is a paper you know these
are the guys that wrote the algorithm
behind it and implemented the package so
they originally wrote it in R and then
later somebody I forgot to I believe was
nicholas ported over to python and you
know i thought was is pretty interesting
package you know it is kind of you know
goal of this talk is to hopefully kind
of walk through it a little bit maybe
save you guys a few hours later if you
ever want to use it on your own so and I
thought the math behind it was pretty
fascinating they kind of used pretty
recent math which is not always the case
so so let's start off what is a level
shift so a level shift and a time series
is an abrupt sustained change of trend
trend level starting from some given
initial time so this is a you know well
so I have an example of some fake data
with the level shift this is you know in
in words definition and you know it's
it's kind of one of those things you
know when you see it I know a level
shift when I see it
and part of the trouble is you know why
this paper was so great I think is it's
up to people to define a good
mathematical statistic that measures
when a level shift happens so all right
so why do I care you know you probably
have
you deal with time series you might have
reasons why level shifts are significant
to you but they can be indicative of a
major event or a paradigm shift and you
know what's what you're measuring in
your time series all right so I have a
few examples you know so this this is
one of the things kind of one of my pet
peeves is when people write a great
package but they give no examples so I
pulled a few examples of stock data
which I you know level chef so you can
really see them you can visual a lot
visualize them and so what why not
so this is SP 500 you know the blue line
is the open value of the S&P 500 from
2005 2010 and you know this black line
black vertical line is where the
algorithm detected you know a level
shift happened okay so you know middle
of 2008 so that's you know what happened
then and oh right the red line is the
moving median so over past 90 days I
think and so there's reason why I chose
moving median rather than moving average
and I'll try to explain that a little
bit a little bit later so next example
combo below late 90s so this is a graph
of Yahoo Yahoo stock from 97 in 2009 and
you know I I made such a wide tale to
the right but because I just think it's
kind of fascinating to look at things
like this you know you know over here
2008 that's that's what we just saw
economic recession and you know the
dot-com bubble was so much bigger it's
crazy so and again this one you know red
is a moving median and I just want to
point out that the the breakout the
level ship isn't detected until that
Plateau and the
red line ends okay so so the the
algorithm because statistically they
defined is more related to the to a
change in median than a change in mean
alright next example Netflix from mid
2012 mid 2013 Netflix started producing
TV shows starting with house of cards on
February 1st
so they've stock jumped and Chipotle
over about the past year their stock
took a little dip because of some ecole
I found it in their food so ok so that's
it for examples that you just I think
this just see how this performs a little
bit that's that's the breakout detection
package and you know that's it actually
performs pretty well
compared to a lot of other level shift
detectors and in general anomaly
detectors or an outlier detectors not
normally so a lot of outlier detectors
are implemented in our and the other
they're starting to be kind of ported
over to a Python but I I think this one
is performance you know I'm not going to
compare them up here you know there's
there's some papers written in that
paper I showed you they compared a few
of them okay so next was is used for so
at c2fo you know the company I worked
for if you were here earlier this
morning CEOs talk
he showed that we have tons of time
series date time series is time series
data so you we have on the order of 100
K time series you know a few a few
hundred thousand and we in our system
you know in our business an event occurs
you know for those people who weren't
here I'm not I'll try not to talk about
too much of this
Pacific's I'll kind of abstract it so an
event occurs possibly creating a level
shift in some of these time series and
for us we want to know did that event
actually create a level shift in some of
these time series which one if so which
ones and so we want an algorithm to you
know go through all these hundreds of
thousands and pick it out so this is an
image that Piero had in his talk so this
is an example of you know what a what
some of our time series might look like
and this is one that has a little bump a
level show so the event that I'm
referring to is you know if we were if
you were there the event is a new buyer
coming into our system and this company
was doing business with that buyer and
we didn't see that until the buyer came
into our system so we have we have more
information about this this company so
this buyer coming into our system
happened here and so you know we know we
can know beforehand like which companies
do business with which buyers that come
into our system buddy we we don't know
exactly how it's going to affect the
time series until it happens and so we
want really you know to have some way of
evaluating that so that's that's kind of
how we use it you know at at c2fo all
right and in general kind of exploratory
analysis or impact analysis so for
example the the examples I showed you of
those stocks you know I kind of how I
came up with them is I I look through
you know S&P 500 stocks pulled them over
in the breakout detection and saw like
do they have interesting breakouts and
then when it detected one I saw kind of
explore and I said oh
was there something interesting that
happen there so it can be you know a
flag to say oh something interesting
might have happened here okay
all right so you know I figured its I'd
say something about insulation so you
can go to this this guy's github here's
the guy I believe he was the guy who
poured it over maybe not
and you these instructions aren't as
github but I if you want you're just
looking at this later they're right here
so you can clone the repository install
this all right so I have a few examples
in Jupiter here this one all right so
first so here's a code that I used to
generate those graphs like that so I
have some imports so when once you've
and I'm using pandas wrapper for the
Yahoo Finance API and once you've
installed breakout detection now you
import it you just import breakout
detection like that and you know so here
get the the data that I want so this is
getting sp500 data and one one catch
that is not totally obvious in the
documentation is that you have to scale
your data between zero and one so that's
you know I didn't really realize that
until I kind of dug into a source code
where they say you know they say you
know make sure your data scale between 0
and 1 so this is you know this scales it
make sure I'm not dividing by 0 so I
take max of max so if my data if the
highest value of my data is is less than
1 I don't want to bother scaling and so
here's how I use the package so it's
it's you know kind of like the calling
fit in in scikit-learn so breakout
detection is kind of an and
it's kind of an empty object and so you
you you'll call it hear you say you
specify which one you want so II DMX's
this standard one they have a few
versions but II DMX is the standard one
and then when you call it evaluates Z Z
was the scaled data of the of the time
series evaluate Z finds the breakout
detection and stores it in a value or
sorry in an in an object sorry a
property of EDM X and they call it get
look so forget locations of the time of
the breakout okay so then you plot it
you you know alright I plotted it you
find the locations and you I plucked the
a vertical line on on the breakout
detection or breakout points alright and
so they do have another algorithm
implemented where you can detect
multiple breakup detections in time
series and you know similar way similar
way of using it except it's called EDM
multi so idiom multi here I'll detect
multiple time there are multiple
breakouts and in the evaluate function
you have two parameters they have to
worry about beta and degree degree I
wouldn't worry about unless you really
want to dig into what it what didn't is
about but basically beta and degree
combined to form a penalisation function
so basically how hard is it to to tell
the or to allow the program to say a
breakout was detected here so basically
they compute a value at each point and
if the value is large enough it Flags it
as a level shift okay
so larger beta corresponds to harder to
have a breakout so we can change it here
I'm still connected yeah point eight
only detect one which I know it's kind
of weird that it's right here but I
don't know so so I really wish it was
around 2008 but I don't I think I have
an idea of why it's detecting over here
but I don't we don't need to go into
that right now and then you know so if
you change it to something less than 0.3
or point zero three it'll detect a few
more okay so it's detected one more okay
great so that's basically how you use it
beta you hire beta it paralyzes more
makes it harder to find to flag
something as breakout lower beta makes
it easier and degree is kind of the
degree of the polynomial that is the now
can think the word so but the the
penalisation factor so there's there's
three values for a degree that it can
take on you know zero one or two zero
negates the penalisation one is
basically constant and two is a linear
scale so okay so that's that's a multi
you know the code behind these these
graphs so let's alright alright so so
now is my super condensed explanation of
the math that's going on behind the the
algorithm and then we'll the next slide
we'll go through the algorithm all right
so so this the paper that they wrote you
know I sort of snapshot of the paper at
the very beginning it's actually pretty
interesting they they use some math
that's developed pretty recently and
they combine two different things you
know one of them is called
energy statistics and the a big thing in
energy statistics is called the energy
distance all right so this is the energy
distance is this calligraphic e of X Y
is you know this this formula expected
value of X minus y minus minus this and
so I'm not I'm not defining anything up
here so if all I'll just say out loud
what these things are so X prime is yeah
so I said x and y are independent random
variables X prime is another random
variable that comes from the same
probability distribution as X but is
independent from X so so if you that
doesn't mean anything to you X prime is
kind of same but different than X so so
I can give an example actually so the
kind of canonical example in explaining
this is you know if you have a coin that
you flip a fair coin it has probability
distribution of half waiting on heads
half waiting on tails so that's the
probability distribution of the event of
flipping a coin the random variable X
associated to that coin is you know you
typically say you know 1 if it lands on
heads 0 that lands on tails so X prime
for example could be the independent
random variable associated to flipping a
different coin so same probability
distribution assuming the coin is fair
so the the two coins have the same
probabilities of planning on heads and
tails but the events of flipping the two
coins are independent
so that's relation of XX Prime and then
similarly Y to Y prime okay so then the
these x i's are random samples of the
random variable X or just samples of the
random variable X
and the Y's are samples of the random
variable Y so we can we can approximate
this energy distance with this formula
okay so you know replacing the integrals
and the expectation values with sums
finite sums and so there's a reason why
it's called what energy comes up in
there but I'm not going to go into that
yeah mostly because I don't totally
understand it but basically the there's
some equations that show up that look
like equations that govern and govern
energy and you know classical mechanics
so alright so the next thing this
combines is something called robust
statistics and the the you know so it's
actually a field of statistics seen it's
not it's not just you know I would like
my statistics to be robust there's
there's a field of statistics that they
try to formalize this idea of making
robust statistics rather than you know
non robust and the slogan I've always
heard with with this is replace the mean
with the median so mean is a non robust
statistic you know if you have you know
if you add on another sorry if you have
a collection of numbers and you take the
mean and then you add on another number
that's you know a lot bigger than any of
the others the mean will change
significantly
yeah but the median however typically
does not so replace the mean with a
median and you know that's that's kind
of a slogan for this field of of stats
but it's not that's not like everything
that they do but that is kind of over
that is what we're gonna do here we are
going to replace the mean with median
and well we are going to get this robust
version of the energy distance
approximation and so the word distance
is in there because it is supposed to be
thought of as a distance between the two
random variables okay so
you know kind of usual way you think of
distance you know bigger number means
they're further apart smaller number of
means are closer together okay so this
does e tilde of X Y is our new robust
version of energy distance between
random variables all right so now that
we have all that the algorithm is is
fairly short if you have your time
series Z 1 through Zn I we just iterate
through the time series and we split it
you know iterate I over you know one 300
and we split Z into different segments
you know X I and Y I and those are our
different random variables and we plug
those into that robust energy distance
and we calculate that for every every
split and then we find the maximum
energy distance or and so the algorithm
actually returns the index of the point
with the maximum energy distance so so
you know saying you know if we if we
split our time series at a certain point
when is a distance between those random
variables the largest and so let's
that's said yeah you know that's and
that's kind of going back to the median
why that's why I graph the rolling
median rather than rolling mean so
that's it thank you
oh yeah so he asked about if there were
times where I observed break out the the
package detecting breakouts where there
were none and you know yes I mean it it
was never at a time where was no
completely flat you know there was
always something kind of strange going
on but uh for instance in the in the the
multi medium multi you can set the beta
the penalisation really low detect many
breakouts and everywhere but yeah it
does but generally it doesn't you know
so in the the EDM X very minimal data
you know I I believe they do have a
buffer but it's pretty small I can't I
can't remember the default but they do
they do require a buffer kind of at the
beginning of your data and then in the
EDM multi you can also set a buffer so
like that will kind of act as a crude
periodicity can think of the word but
kind of a crude periodicity like a
factor so if you don't want to detect
breakouts too close to another you can
set set this buffer parameter I believe
they call it max next size in the
well so so I mean I don't know the other
what you kill distance but one thing
that this is why this is advantageous is
because of what I was kind of hand
waving and saying you know medians are
more more robust and means this does
perform better when your time series has
lots of kind of spikes and other noise
so they they do have some good examples
or they have one good example where
there's kind of some spikes in the time
series and it detects level shift even
though there's going to love noise going
on and so which is something that I kind
of a a short following of some of the
other packages that I've observed like
maybe I think change points and TS
outliers they tend to detect level
shifts at points that are just kind of
spikes so yeah so the main one of the
main advantages of this is that it's
kind of it's a little less sensitive to
noise so it can still fun trying to find
that level shift
mmm
so yes our bus is that against
seasonality and I so keen and I don't
know if I totally understand the
question like okay yes you you do have
to well so if you know that seasonality
you can put in there is a parameter in
the median multi for oh yeah I just said
I guess but that does act as kind of a
seasonality component so that it it does
it will say you know don't detect a
breakout protection for another whatever
you specify and you know typically it's
a good idea so if you are dealing with
data that's on the scale of of years and
maybe you want to put in and you have
maybe have data point for each week you
want maybe want to put in 13 or each
quarter yeah so so the idiom multi does
have some some capacity for dealing with
seasonality
I mean the data or yeah not not really
that I've seen that you know I think I I
kind of use as an exploratory thing you
know maybe there's more sophisticated
way to go about it but um oh sorry I
didn't I'm not repeating questions um so
he asks about basically how do you know
what to set data to and you know I kind
of want to be honest I kind of play
around with it a little bit you know
like like I said we have a large number
of time series and so I look and see I
get a beta that kind of works for a few
you know take a few and you know our
time series are pretty similar and in
nature so if I find a good beta then I'm
fairly confident that it'll be okay for
the other ones
um but for now really for detecting
level shifts this is kind of a main one
you know I I've evaluated some other
ones and this was the most performant
for our needs one bad thing is this is
very specialized you know there's other
packages that detecting level chefs
whatever additive outliers and
innovative outliers whatever they're
called so this is this is very
specialized to just level shifts
so asking about how robust is it against
non-uniform data and so maybe if you
have a a gap in our data so I'm not sure
so do you are you assuming your gap is
filled with you maybe zeros or you know
you just fill in the gap and kind of
glue them together I mean I think then
it would most likely detect a breakout
you know there you know you'll see there
was a dip there one so I don't know yeah
it so I would assume maybe with
detective level shift you know where
there's some missing data because
there's a sharp drop there but yeah
so the first question was on if there's
a significant change in volatility over
time in the time series does that have
an effect on the the algorithm and you
know not really that I've seen and and I
don't know I don't know why I don't
think it should so from what I
understand I think it should be fairly
consistent on you know if you're yeah if
you do have some change in invariance or
volatility over time then I haven't seen
really much difference and you know it
still performs really well and from what
I understand that that's kind of not
what it's detecting so I think it should
do it so the second question was so it
was a second question so so right so
here's asking if the algorithm changes
as you get more data and so as far as
the Nike DMX the one that just attacks
one you know it'll it'll tech it'll
detect the greatest one the largest one
so if you get more data and there's a
much larger level shift it'll it will
prefer that one over another one that
was smaller and the EDM X sorry the EDM
multi it will it doesn't you know if you
have another big one that comes along
later on it should still detect the
earlier ones you know it doesn't really
change those well maybe I should be
careful there but unless unless you have
a have a most you specified like a
seasonality
on it and said you know I don't want
another level shift within a certain
time and they don't kind of bump a bump
the smaller one
but so he's asking what what does this
do on spikes and yeah it'll it'll ignore
it so I won't it won't detect that as
you know to level shifts or or 1/1 level
shift
okay thank you again